ufc who could replace dana white i've
asked this question from quite a few
different people
just curious you know what your thoughts
on this and i don't think
i mean everybody
can see something said daniel cormier he
said daniel couldn't do my job but who
do you think could replace i don't think
nobody can replace dana white i don't
think so i mean i mean to do to be as
good as they know it was i think some
someone can come
and fill the old
maybe not be like dana white be better
at certain things that dana white
maybe something i know it is not very
diplomatic so it could be
it could be more diplomatic but maybe to
to be a promoter to to be intense as as
unique as diana white is only one guy is
dana white
it doesn't mean his job cannot be taken
and he cannot be replaced i think
everybody can be
replaced
but
nobody everybody is unique and everybody
has a different unique personality and
dana white is he's very curious man he's
in the unique category yes so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]
you